a critical and urgent new warning for
parents of toddlers and babies this is
coming from the consumer product safety
commission and meg oliver is here at the
table with more on it may good morning
to you good morning to all of you this
is a warning not a recall but it's in
regards to two popular fisher-price baby
rockers that may be dangerous if not
used according to directions mattel
which owns fisher-price and the
commission said in a joint statement
infant to toddler rockers and newborn to
toddler rockers are tied to the deaths
of at least 13 infants between 2009 and
2021. another separate warning was
issued for a popular rocker made by the
brand kids2 announcing it was involved
in at least one reported death in 2019.
as you may remember this comes after the
agency recalled a similar fisher-price
product in 2019 after it was linked more
than 30 infant deaths over a 10-year
period and last year fisher-price
recalled two rockers that were found to
have been responsible for four infant
deaths in those cases the infants were
placed on their backs unrestrained in
the product and later found on their
stomachs according to officials in a
statement to cbs news fisher price urged
consumers to never use the rockers for
sleep never leave children unsupervised
or unrestrained and never add bedding
material to the product we reached out
to kids too for a statement and did not
yet hear back last month the biden
administration signed the safe sleep for
babies act into law
banning the sale of some crib bumpers
and inclined infant sleepers but the big
question is here why are we hearing
about these deaths now years later the
head of the consumer product safety
commission is pleading with congress to
overturn the so-called
gag rule it requires the agency to seek
permission from a company before they
warn the public about a product she's
totally nuts absolutely and they just
learned about these these deaths about
two months ago but they couldn't say
anything it's that's bonkers that's
bonkers it's such a tough situation
because what parents are using those
products because they're desperate to
take a shower they got to cook dinner
they need a break they need to sit down
and this is where you put your kid and
inevitably because you're exhausted if
the baby falls asleep you often fall
asleep and now what they're saying is
don't do that and i don't think a gag
order should apply to anything like this
absolutely not life-saving information
that parents need to know these deaths
go back to 2009. how about that who meg
thank you